welcome to Sun Springs retirement
community have the time of your life for
the rest of your life well you got
everything you could have a name over a
hundred cloves brings you the Sun sprays
I'm just here to die uh-huh there's not
enough erections around here as it is
but since you're a cheerleader and my
mother was very sick so I quit the team
maybe you should give it another shot we
want to start a cheerleading Club who
you be cheering for ourselves
show us what you bought yes my husband
what'd he say over my dead body that was
passed
a little too fast we could do with a
little help we want you to be our prayer
the oldest category is 18 plus we're 18
plus 18 plus 50 I'm not gonna lie to you
it's gonna be a lot tougher than I
thought why not jump too much I get this
I had my knee replaced did I mention I
had some idiot yeah you did along with
the shocking amount of other information
all right then what about you me no I'm
fine I'm bit as a bill
why didn't you tell me a dime you were
dying yesterday and you're gonna be
dying next week in the meantime should
be dancing your ass yourself I can't do
this we're all so worried about what
everyone else is thinking
and of course the only thing that really
matters is what we think of ourselves
[Music]
pray to him get pregnant
always wanted to date a cheerleader
[Applause]
now I know you're scared I'm scared too
but there's one I've had to go out there
I've never had a grandma before and now
it's like I have eight you're one of us
now except with higher boobies
[Music]